so uh i want to start with how excited i
am to see the entire series um what are
you what are you most excited for people
to see in the rings of power
i'm excited that that we get to sort of
show a world that is just imagination
it's just pure imagination that has been
stretched to every single extreme um and
i'm excited for people to see all of the
work that has been put into it not just
by cast but from
crew
and production and just to really see
everything that's been built that's been
created that's been imagined
um
and to sort of really immerse people
into the world um that we are fortunate
enough to play in
yeah i was going to say i i really love
that question because i think
i think actually i think yeah what
exactly what megan said regarding the
crew i think to see that there was such
a huge huge huge part of
the series and the story and just
because you don't see them physically in
on screen everything you see on screen
is such a product of their
work and and
um and their creativity so i'm really
excited to for them for the audience to
see all the worlds and
and all the work of everyone so you're
saying that the two of you didn't build
all the sets yourself
no
[Laughter]
no i wish i did because they look
incredible i would never have done as
good a job as they did
for lord of the rings fans uh what do
you think they might be surprised to
learn about the actual making of the
show i think actually how much um scale
work is involved
i think it's not something that you see
a lot of hopefully because it'll it'll
be edited in a way where you can't
actually tell i hope i'm sure but um
uh but i think that's quite surprising
is actually realizing how how
you know we have scale doubles and we
went through a
scale academy is what they called it
which was a couple of hours of being
taught and told about the technicalities
of scale work um
and so and just how much
just how much that actually is
especially you know in in our story how
much we we work with that and
um that sometimes you know even though
it looks like we're acting with each
other with
other beings that we may not be that
it's it might be a scale double or it
might be them on a ledge and i think
that's quite surprising
yeah i agree i agree yeah i actually
didn't know that you guys did that and
that's another reason i'm excited for
the series i'm sure that the the
illusion is gonna be fantastic
yeah i hope so
um i'm confident um how would you
actually describe the scope of the
series i think there's i think there's a
lot of worlds and a lot of dynamic
characters and i think that
i think that that will hopefully make
for a really
um immersive and engaging experience and
that you'll and cinematic experience i
think actually yes scope-wise it it will
hopefully feel like you're watching
something very cinematic and um
something that will hopefully feel like
it should be
either like on a projector on a wall or
on a bigger screen if if
you're able to
um
just something that feels like you're
actually in the screen with us i think
that hopefully that will be
that will be what's what's manifested on
screen
without spoilers
which is your favorite episode of the
eight and why i like oh
there are so many elements and lots of
the episodes that i really enjoy i
really like
stuff that happens in two
something happens in three
i like seven i like seven let's go with
seven i like seven seven is great other
people have said seven so now i'm very
curious about seven yeah i don't know if
things kick off well i mean yeah because
it's the episode yeah before the finale
but um
things happen in seven and i think i
actually also really like too i like to
we've got a lot of fun stuff into fun
stuffing too but i like what happens
with anyway yeah but it's sort of like
so if you think of two and seven that's
when sort of the adventure begins and
when it's sort of
you know like yeah it's the journey of a
series right so that's kind of it's
exciting it's exciting the whole thing
that's right
i'm all in um i already have to rap i'm
just gonna say uh seriously i can't wait
to talk in more detail about the series
and um you know have a fantastic day
thank you thank you you too nice to meet
you